bonsoir ou la taz merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france à l'heure où
vous recombiner pour quatre jours au
liban
l'assouplissement des restrictions aura
été de courte durée
votre réaction nous ne comprenons pas la
durée de quatre jours
on sait très bien que un confinement
doit durer au moins deux semaines pour
que des cas surtout qui nous viennent de
l'étranger soit découvert découvert dans
ce cas là le libanais n'a plus confiance
en son gouvernement ni dans la ce ce
régime irresponsables qui nous
gouvernent
alors du coup il ya beaucoup de
spéculations certains disent qu'ils ont
besoin de ces quatre jours pour faire
passer la farine et le et le fuel en
syrie la farine et le fuel qui a acheté
par le vin libanais mais qui est vendue
à la syrie pour le compte de certains
ministres et de certains partis
politiques alors nous n'avons pas
confiance que c'est que ce soit un
confinement tente le corona parce que
quatre jours vraiment ça ça n'a pas de
sens c'est vrai que quatre jours ça peut
être étonnant on rappelle ce contexte
tendu un an au liban il y avait des
manifestations malgré le confinement
vous y voyez justement un lien ces
manifestations et ont reconquis à
nouveau oui je le crois 1
c'est vrai que
le taux et aoc et on s'attendait à ça
parce que bon entre le corona et la peur
du corona et la fin parce que le pays
est dans un désastre économique et
financier très graves comme il y en a
jamais vu au liban les gens ont vraiment
vraiment faim les riches et les pauvres
n'ont pas accès à leur argent
personne n'a accès à l'argent ou très
peu et bon mais les gens en ont marre et
les gens se manifestent un peu partout
dans le pays et certains n'ont pas le
prix du masque elle nous n'avons pas
manquer demain s'il y en a nous n'avons
pas manqué de soins médicaux parce que
les établissements privés ont été à la
hauteur jusqu'à présent mais par contre
les gens n'ont pas l'argent pour payer
un masque donc pour se payer un une
protection alors il s'en fout et moi
aussi je veux j'ai manifesté mais au
moins j'avais une protection
certains gens manifestent sans
protection et il met en danger soient
eux-mêmes et les et l'armée et on a vu
dernièrement ddd sound à des officiers
de l'armée qui ont été atteints par le
courant à mu alors vous venez de le dire
et tout le monde le sait effectivement
le liban le liban dans une situation
économique catastrophique
le fait de reconfirmer on imagine que ça
va accentuer encore plus cette chute
économique puisque comme chez nous
l'économie est totalement à l'arrêt
l'économie dans un pays comme la france
qui n'a pas des challenges régionaux
comme un comme le liban nous sommes pris
par la crise causée par le coroner par
la crise économique catastrophique quand
vous l'avez mais a précisé
et surtout par un bras de fer qui se
passe dans la région entre la syrie et
l'irak le liban dar es salaam nous
sommes vraiment pris dans un étau
impossible est bon ce confinement de
quatre jours n'a fait que
augmenter les doutes vis-à-vis de ce
gouvernement du hezbollah qui essayent
par tous les moyens de faire passer le
temps et de faire passer certaines
incertaine certains deals si vous voulez
pour renflouer les caisses du réseau la
ss quoique c'est comme ça qu'on le voit
alors confinement au pab je ne pense pas
que les gens vont rester à la maison
sincèrement je pense que les rues seront
à nouveau plein dans les dans les jours
qui viennent peut-être pas dans tout le
liban peut-être ment pas dans beyrouth
mais surtout dans les dents les dans les
villes aux noms reçu dans la baie cas
alors il pouvait me retenir il ya un
élément très important au liban en ce
moment c'est que le recours au fmi
semble désormais acté
beaucoup y voient en tout cas certains y
voient une mise sous tutelle peut être
une perte de la souveraineté nationale
du pays est ce que c'est un avis que
vous partagez ou au contraire vous voyez
ça comme une opportunité
vous pensez que nous avons une
souveraineté au liban est ce qu'on l'a
eue depuis vingt ans les syriens étaient
là les syriens sont partis l'iran a pris
la relève et évidemment à mon avis il
nous faut une capitale internationale
qui qui va pouvoir peut-être aidé le
libanais le peuple libanais à se
débarrasser de la classe politique
mafieuse qui a vidé les caisses du pays
qui a volé plus que 300 milliards de
dollars qui sont partagés entre les
leaders des partis sectaire politique
je peux vous dire madame que oui
effectivement nous prions que le fmi
prenne le dessus
à ce stade là sincèrement le peuple
libanais s'en fout de la souveraineté
parce qu'elle n'existe pas de toute
façon merson ce sont que des slogans
voilà merci beaucoup roulent à talent
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle vous êtes
analyste politique merci à vous